[Musique]
on a décliné un plan de soutien en trois
temps en trois composantes évidemment un
plan de soutien économique un plan de
soutien sanitaire et puis surtout un
plan de soutien qu'on a appelé la
solidarité de proximité et donc cette
semaine dans les plus de 20 mille boîtes
aux lettres de la ville nous allons
déposer des questionnaires et bien
entendu les annonces du président dupré
ministres et des médecins disant qu'il
faut surtout que les plus fragiles
restent à l'écart se protègent restent
chez eux le plus possible on sait que ça
s'il il faut rompre aussi cette logique
que d'isolement auxquels peuvent être
confrontés nos aînés sur les locaux dont
nous sommes titulaires
voilà on a fait des franchises de loyer
on a été au rendez vous on a fait des
exonérations on a fait exact et
normalement d'exonération de droite
théâtre on permet bien évidemment la
vente à emporter donc c'est on a permis
ça serait pour l'est les commerces donc
on a aussi des permanences
on va mettre en place avec l'ensemble
des élus on a de la chance d'avoir des
élus et experts sur la question on a
notamment à l'ancienne prison de la
chambre de commerce des yvelines qui est
là il faut j'ai donc on va faire des
guichets d'accueil pour recenser les
difficultés pour après les orienter sur
les mécanismes dead on va organiser très
certainement une médiation autour des
loyers commerciaux parce que c'est leur
sujet voilà moi le le crédit d'impôt qui
a été voté qui a été décidé par le
gouvernement à hauteur de 30 % en un
mois de loyer ça suffit pas il faut
aller au delà et là il faut
véritablement que nous ont pu jouer
notre rôle d'intermédiation entre les
propriétaires et les locataires
on va les mettre en place en fin de
semaine on a acheté nous mêmes des tests
antigénique alors qu'est-ce qu'on en
fait déjà on va alimenter la médecine de
ville
ils auront comme ça en stock avec des
patients symptomatiques qui viennent les
voir il faut que ce soit réservé
vraiment patients symptomatiques
c'est vraiment très important